Katrina:  那就把这个拿了
Katrina: Then let's take this.
Tasha: 算了吧那把这个拿了吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's take this.
Katrina:  好谦让哈哈哈
Katrina: So polite, haha.
Katrina:  还有什么
Katrina: What else?
Tasha: 我们还找
Tasha: We're still looking.
Tasha: 我们还买了个芋
Tasha: We also bought some taro.
Tasha: 魔芋魔芋魔芋啊
Tasha: Konjac, konjac, konjac.
你们有买魔芋吗
Speaker: Did you buy konjac?
Tasha: 你们有买魔芋吗
Tasha: Did you buy konjac?
Lucia: 我们没有吧
Lucia: We don't have it, right?
Katrina:  没有那就够了
Katrina: If not, then it's enough.
Tasha: 那就行那我把豆腐拿走
Tasha: Alright then, I'll take the tofu away.
Katrina:  火锅调料要买蒜吗
Katrina: Do we need to buy garlic for the hot pot seasoning?
Alice: 哦蒜买了
Alice: Oh, we bought garlic.
Alice: 哦蒜有这个
Alice: Oh, we have garlic.
Jake:拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a picture.
Alice:有这种蒜
Alice: We have this kind of garlic.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就这么草率
Katrina: Hahaha, so hasty.
Alice: 露出来了
Alice: It's exposed.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Katrina:  非常的潦草啊
Katrina: Very sloppy.
Jake: 再来
Jake: Let's do it again.
Shure:  我们少个人
Shure: We're missing someone.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's the person?
Alice:他去放豆腐了
Alice: He went to put the tofu away.
Jake:好等他回来
Jake: Alright, let's wait for him to come back.
Katrina:  哦这个是什么
Katrina: Oh, what is this?
Alice:板栗
Alice: Chestnut.
Tasha: 这个店没有了
Tasha: This store doesn't have it anymore.
Tasha: 别的店可能会有
Tasha: Other stores might have it.
Lucia: 哎我没有见过这种板栗
Lucia: Oh, I've never seen this kind of chestnut.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: It's fine.
Shure:  哎萝卜胡萝卜咸萝卜嫩芽子
Shure: Hey, radish, carrot, salted radish, young shoots.
Shure:  香椿好韭菜嘞
Shure: Chinese toon, and chives.
Lucia: 哈哈哈观察一下观察一下
Lucia: Hahaha, let's observe, observe.
Shure:  变异性了
Shure: It's mutated.
Alice:这还卧了个蛋呢
Alice: There's an egg in here.
Jake: 咱重建一下
Jake: Let's rebuild it.
Jake: 让他重建一下
Jake: Let him rebuild it.
Shure:  香菜
Shure: Cilantro.
Shure:  青椒哎
Shure: Green pepper.
Alice: 这还是个公的
Alice: This one's a male.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 公的哈哈哈
Lucia: A male, hahaha.
Lucia: 发现盲点
Lucia: Found a blind spot.
Jake:哈哈哈揣俩蛋
Jake: Hahaha, carrying two eggs.
Katrina: 来吧一起
Katrina: Come on, together.
Tasha: 这家店没有了
Tasha: This store doesn't have it anymore.
Alice: 荔浦鱼头
Alice: Lipu fish head
Tasha: 这家店没有
Tasha: This place doesn't have it.
Tasha: 另一家店有
Tasha: Another place does.
Katrina:  有什么
Katrina: What do they have?
Alice: 在哪说
Alice: Where did they say?
Tasha: 说很近
Tasha: They said it's nearby.
Tasha: 另外一家很近
Tasha: The other place is close.
Alice: 他能调货吗
Alice: Can he transfer the goods?
Lucia: 我们刚才找到了保鲜膜
Lucia: We just found the cling wrap.
Jake:拍拍拍个照拍个照拍个照吧
Jake: Let's take a photo, take a photo.
Tasha: 他调不了
Tasha: He can't transfer it.
Lucia: 他一起吗
Lucia: Is he coming with us?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 他是真的吗
Tasha: Is he for real?
Alice: 假的
Alice: Fake.
Jake:来拍照了
Jake: Come on, let's take a photo.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:好放回去
Jake: Alright, put it back.
Tasha: 为什么要跟一只鸡合照
Tasha: Why are we taking a photo with a chicken?
Lucia: 这是顺手的
Lucia: It was just handy.
Katrina:  哈哈因为太辣了
Katrina: Haha, because it's too spicy.
Jake:因为看到了
Jake: Because we saw it.
Alice:这是下蛋公鸡
Alice: This is a laying rooster.
Shure: 下蛋公鸡
Shure: A laying rooster.
Shure:  公鸡下蛋
Shure: A rooster that lays eggs.
Shure: 公鸡下蛋公鸡中的战斗机
Shure: A rooster that lays eggs, a fighter jet among roosters.
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appearing.
Shure:  行大家的表情一样的僵硬
Shure: Alright, everyone's expressions are equally stiff.
Shure:  我就哈哈哈放心了
Shure: Haha, I'm relieved.
Shure:  哈哈哈像
Shure: Haha, just like...
Jake:相对民众
Jake: Facing the crowd.
Katrina:  这好像是个动图吧
Katrina: This seems like a gif.
Katrina:  是动图吧
Katrina: It's a gif, right?
Katrina:  我跟你讲我们原来那个
Katrina: Let me tell you, our previous...
Shure:  是动图我们办公室拍照
Shure: It's a gif, we took photos in our office.
Shure:  然后有一个是原来当过idol的那种
Shure: And there was one who used to be an idol.
Shure:  嗯然后就
Shure: Yeah, and then...
Shure:  他跟我们就感觉不是一个涂层的
Shure: He felt like he wasn't on the same level as us.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Shure:  就人家那个表情管理和装造我靠
Shure: The way they manage their expressions and their looks, oh my god.
Alice:超能
Alice: Super capable.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 呃有个音效你去听一下
Tasha: Uh, there's a sound effect, go listen to it.
Lucia: 没有音效是他模仿的
Lucia: There's no sound effect, he was mimicking it.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 你给每个人都看一眼
Tasha: Show it to everyone.
Tasha: 哈哈哈然后我们去买保鲜膜
Tasha: Hahaha, then let's go buy some cling film.
Katrina: 弹舌吗
Katrina: Tongue trill?
Alice:你去学俄语吧
Alice: You should learn Russian.
Tasha: 买个羽绒吧
Tasha: Buy a down jacket.
Katrina: 我不会
Katrina: I can't do it.
Tasha: 还有个薄荷
Tasha: There's also some mint.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 不一定能买的到
Tasha: We might not be able to buy it.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And that's it.
Shure:  我原来也不会
Shure: I couldn't do it before either.
Shure:  我记得有一天滑个滑板
Shure: I remember one day I was skateboarding.
Tasha:奶粉也不一定
Tasha: Baby formula might not be available either.
Shure:  然后一下就会了
Shure: And suddenly I could do it.
Jake:再拍一次管理一下
Jake: Let's shoot again, manage it.
Jake: 能管理的了吗
Jake: Can it be managed?
Shure:  管理不了
Shure: No, it can't be managed.
Lucia: 管理一下管理一下
Lucia: Manage it, manage it.
Jake: 管理一下好
Jake: Okay, manage it.
Shure:  怎么怎么管理一下
Shure: How do you manage it?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: I have no idea.
Shure:  就是看着像正常人类一点
Shure: Just look more like a normal human being.
Katrina: 禁止禁止 10秒钟
Katrina: Stop, stop for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那很难那很难
Jake: That's really hard.
Jake: 这回来个10秒的
Jake: Let's try for 10 seconds this time.
Shure:  10秒
Shure: 10 seconds.
Katrina:  10秒他保持不了10秒进去
Katrina: He can't hold it for 10 seconds.
Jake: 那就酝酿一会
Jake: Then let's prepare for a bit.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe.
Jake: 你的音效声音
Jake: Your sound effect.
Lucia: 看大家的管理成果
Lucia: Look at everyone's management results.
Tasha: 表情管理成果吗
Tasha: Expression management results?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Katrina:  可以无所谓
Katrina: It doesn't matter.
Alice: 鸦雀无声
Alice: Not a peep.
Lucia: 鸦雀无声
Lucia: Not a peep.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's okay.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Katrina:  还缺啥吗
Katrina: Are we missing anything?
Tasha: 还缺保鲜膜
Tasha: We still need plastic wrap.
Tasha: 你们买一下
Tasha: Can you guys get it?
Katrina: 买了
Katrina: Got it.
Lucia: 买了我们买了保鲜膜
Lucia: We got the plastic wrap.
Lucia: 保鲜膜买了
Lucia: Plastic wrap is bought.
Lucia: 找到了
Lucia: Found it.
Tasha: 还有什么
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crusts.
Alice:荔浦芋头
Alice: Li Pu taro.
Tasha: 芋头没有
Tasha: No taro.
Shure:  杨老板头大了
Shure: Jake's overwhelmed.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
Tasha: 薄荷买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy mint?
Katrina:  没有买薄荷哎
Katrina: Didn't buy mint.
Alice: 没有薄荷可能
Alice: Maybe there's no mint.
Tasha: 是没有薄荷
Tasha: There is no mint.
Jake:没有这些都很便宜听起来
Jake: None of these are very expensive, right?
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure:  知道什么叫聚沙成塔
Shure: Do you know the saying "gathering sand to make a tower"?
Shure:  压死骆驼的最后一根稻草吗
Shure: Or "the last straw that breaks the camel's back"?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart crusts.
Katrina: 薄荷蛋挞皮薄荷
Katrina: Mint, tart crusts, mint.
Jake: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Jake: The last tart crust.
Lucia: 最后一个蛋挞皮
Lucia: The last tart crust.
Alice: 实在没有薄荷
Alice: There's really no mint.
Alice:要不然下楼摘点叶子吧
Alice: How about we go downstairs and pick some leaves?
Shure:  咱们去那个那什么
Shure: Let's go to that place...
Shure:  买一盆新的就行
Shure: And just buy a new pot.
Alice: 把我们那花剪点当装饰
Alice: Let's cut some flowers from our place for decoration.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: There's none.
Alice:你在找啥
Alice: What are you looking for?
Alice: 蛋挞皮
Alice: Tart crusts.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Katrina:  薄荷好像确实没看见
Katrina: Seems like we really didn't see any mint.
Alice:这蛋挞
Alice: This egg tart
Shure:  烘焙区是不是在前面
Shure: Is the baking area in the front?
Tasha: 那吗
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  好像是吧我刚才看到烘焙俩字
Shure: I think so. I just saw the word "baking."
Tasha: 烘焙区是烘口的
Tasha: The baking area is for baking.
Tasha: 对不是这儿
Tasha: Yeah, it's not here.
修硕; 我看看
Shure: Let me take a look.
Jake: 能带我起来吗
Jake: Can you help me up?
Jake: 啊小心小心
Jake: Ah, careful, careful.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia: 这些非工作人员请勿触碰
Lucia: Non-staff members, please do not touch.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Tasha: 他说烘焙区里面有烘蛋挞
Tasha: He said there are egg tarts in the baking area.
Jake:我也不碰了
Jake: I won't touch it either.
Lucia: 小心危险
Lucia: Be careful, it's dangerous.
Katrina: 老北京豆汁
Katrina: Traditional Beijing soy milk.
Alice:有熟的
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure:  嚯跟后台要
Shure: Whoa, ask the backstage.
Katrina: 拿两盒豆汁
Katrina: Get two boxes of soy milk.
Tasha: 啊  没有哎
Tasha: Ah, there's none.
Lucia: 但实话说
Lucia: But honestly,
Lucia: 我也挺好奇
Lucia: I'm also curious.
Lucia: 他们上面那个Logic chain是干嘛用的
Lucia: What is the logic chain on top used for?
Tasha: 你好我想问有哎蛋挞皮吗蛋挞皮
Tasha: Hi, I want to ask if you have egg tart crusts, egg tart crusts.
Tasha: 啊超市里没有
Tasha: Ah, the supermarket doesn't have it.
Tasha: 应该在冻柜里吧
Tasha: It should be in the freezer, right?
Tasha: 好像有蛋挞皮
Tasha: Seems like there's egg tart crusts.
Lucia: 我们诶这个好可爱
Lucia: Oh, this is so cute.
Tasha: 这都没有呀
Tasha: There's none of this either.
Lucia: 啊扫描一下
Lucia: Ah, scan it.
Tasha: 服务台在那吗
Tasha: Is the service desk over there?
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Egg tart crusts.
Jake: 从上往下拍会好吗
Jake: Will it look good shooting from above?
Lucia: 呃会好一点
Lucia: Uh, it'll look better.
Lucia: 一般来说这个角度会显得人脸瘦一点
Lucia: Generally, this angle makes the face look slimmer.
Tasha: 在吃伞底下就应该喝椰子
Tasha: Under the umbrella, you should drink coconut water.
Jake:那就让他从上往下拍
Jake: Then let him shoot from above.
Alice:蛋挞皮能用啥替代呢
Alice: What can we use to substitute egg tart crusts?
Tasha: 没有东西能替代
Tasha: Nothing can replace them.
Alice: 馄饨皮
Alice: Wonton wrappers
Alice: 馄饨皮刷蛋液行吗
Alice: Can we brush the wonton wrappers with egg wash?
Jake: 齐吧人不齐
Jake: Is everyone here or not?
Alice: 哇他们家还出这个了
Alice: Wow, they even have this!
Lucia: 我们可以比个心
Lucia: We can make a heart shape.
Tasha: 超市有蛋挞皮吗蛋挞皮
Tasha: Does the supermarket have tart shells? Tart shells.
小微；蛋挞皮和蛋挞叶
Tasha: Tart shells and tart leaves.
Jake:哎呦我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Lucia: 那就等10秒
Lucia: Then just wait for 10 seconds.
Tasha: 有吗咦
Tasha: Is there? Hmm.
Tasha: 是什么牌子
Tasha: What brand is it?
Jake: 可以有点糊啊
Jake: It might be a bit blurry.
Jake:这聚焦怎么聚哪去了
Jake: Why is the focus off?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Lucia: 谢谢好像有那么一点点糊
Lucia: Thanks, it seems a bit blurry.
Lucia: 但你是清楚的
Lucia: But you're clear.
Tasha: 啊没有那就只
Tasha: Ah, no, then just...
Jake: 聚我头上去了
Jake: It focused on my head.
Tasha: 能在网上买了
Tasha: You can buy it online.
Jake: 我这个目标太大
Jake: My head is too big of a target.
Alice:这是什么柜子啊
Alice: What kind of cabinet is this?
Alice: 免费领菜
Alice: Free vegetables.
Lucia: 没事说明他这个抓住重点想拍老板
Lucia: It's okay, it means they want to focus on the boss.
Tasha: 你看就是今天可以免费领的区
Tasha: Look, this is the area for free vegetables today.
Alice:有我们要的吗
Alice: Do we need anything?
Jake: 现在对了好
Jake: Now it's right, okay.
Alice:嗯这是大馒头
Alice: Hmm, this is a big steamed bun.
Katrina:  我俩还比心吗
Katrina: Are we still making a heart?
Lucia: 啊可以或者
Lucia: Ah, we can or...
Alice:吃火锅需要面吗
Alice: Do we need noodles for hot pot?
Tasha: 呃你有会员吗
Tasha: Uh, do you have a membership?
Katrina: 又来哈哈哈
Katrina: Here we go again, hahaha.
Tasha: 要x会员
Tasha: You need an x membership.
Lucia: 又没聚住吗
Lucia: Did it lose focus again?
Shure: 5秒就行
Shure: 5 seconds is enough.
Alice:x会员好像不是吧
Alice: The x membership isn't necessary, right?
Tasha: 黄金会员钻石会员的主口
Tasha: Gold membership, diamond membership's main entrance.
Tasha: 普通会员拉倒
Tasha: Regular membership, forget it.
Tasha: 要298一年
Tasha: It costs 298 a year.
Alice:那种的
Alice: That kind.
Katrina:  他俩找蛋挞皮去了吗
Katrina: Did they go to find the tart shells?
Jake: 好要压死我了
Jake: Okay, this is going to crush me.
Jake: 难了
Jake: It's hard.
Tasha: 不然我天天都领
Tasha: Otherwise, I would get them every day.
Jake:蛋挞皮
Jake: Tart shells.
Jake: 哦在那
Jake: Oh, over there.
Shure:  哦你们看过人类宇宙探索编辑部吗
Shure: Oh, have you guys seen the Human Universe Exploration Editorial?
Katrina: 没看没看过
Katrina: No, haven't seen it.
Lucia: 啊哪里
Lucia: Huh, where?
Katrina: 当然可火了没看
Katrina: Of course, it's super popular, haven't seen it.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yep.
Shure:  一个算是文艺片吧
Shure: It's kind of an art film, I guess.
Katrina:  什么呀薄荷
Katrina: What, mint?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Tasha: 没有问过服务台了
Tasha: Haven't asked the service desk.
Katrina:  薄荷和那个什么芋泥
Katrina: Mint and that taro thing.
Katrina:  还有那个蛋挞皮都没有
Katrina: And those tart shells, none of them.
Alice: 对别的都可以
Alice: Yeah, everything else is fine.
Tasha: 但是蛋挞液自己做的话
Tasha: But if you're making the tart filling yourself,
Tasha: 要旺仔牛奶就行了
Tasha: you just need Wangzai milk.
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, got it.
Lucia: 这个是用来送打包外卖的
Lucia: This is for delivering takeout.
Lucia: 刚才看到一个袋子过去
Lucia: Just saw a bag pass by.
Lucia: 我终于知道它是干什么的了
Lucia: I finally know what it's for.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  自己做麻烦吗
Katrina: Is it troublesome to make it yourself?
Tasha: 不麻烦
Tasha: Not troublesome.
Jake:他就是他
Jake: He is who he is.
Jake:走几步很难吗
Jake: Is it hard to take a few steps?
Alice: 要放淡奶油吧
Alice: You need to add heavy cream, right?
Lucia: 可能是
Lucia: Maybe.
Tasha: 对淡奶油炼乳白砂糖蛋液
Tasha: Yes, heavy cream, condensed milk, white sugar, and egg yolk.
Lucia: 给大家造成一种高科技的错觉
Lucia: Creates the illusion of high-tech.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 蛋蛋液就行了
Tasha: Just egg yolk will do.
Tasha: 还有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: And Wangzai milk.
Alice: 蛋挞皮的话那个
Alice: As for tart shells,
Lucia: 但实际上这玩意很像蒸汽朋克时代那种话筒
Lucia: But actually, this thing looks like a microphone from the steampunk era.
Alice:蛋挞皮能自己做吗蛋挞皮是不是得
Alice: Can you make tart shells yourself? Tart shells need...
Lucia: 可以外送了
Lucia: We can do delivery now.
Alice: 对闪溢的
Alice: Yeah, for Shanyi.
Tasha: 但是我想要
Tasha: But I want...
Tasha: 叫什么奥昆
Tasha: What's it called, Oken?
Tasha: 奥昆
Tasha: Oken.
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 呃精品
Tasha: Uh, a premium item.
Jake:草履虫
Jake: Paramecium.
Lucia: 我就是这么以为的
Lucia: That's what I thought.
Katrina: 就是你对牌子有要求吗
Katrina: Do you have any brand preferences?
Jake: 嗯大细菌
Jake: Hmm, big bacteria.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮
Tasha: Tart shell.
Jake: 大肠杆菌
Jake: E. coli.
修硕；巨噬细胞
Shure: Macrophage.
Shure:  对大肠杆菌
Shure: Right, E. coli.
Shure:  大肠杆菌
Shure: E. coli.
Katrina: 你那指甲还挺好看的
Katrina: Your nails look nice.
Lucia: 撒了那种
Lucia: Sprinkled with that kind.
Lucia: 就是生日蛋糕上面那种小糖碎的草莓
Lucia: Like the little sugar bits on birthday cakes, with strawberries.
Katrina: 是裸色吗
Katrina: Is it nude color?
Katrina: 我我我特想抠
Katrina: I really want to pick at it.
Jake:啊这甜甜圈
Jake: Ah, this donut.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Jake:吃了一口
Jake: Took a bite.
Katrina: 如果我镶钻了
Katrina: If I had diamonds on it...
Tasha: 我也是我我刚做的
Tasha: Me too, I just got mine done.
Shure:  这后面是一个姜饼人
Shure: There's a gingerbread man at the back.
Shure:  所以就是没有
Shure: So there's none.
Alice:没有只能外卖买了吧
Alice: No, we can only buy it through delivery.
Jake:是一个
Jake: It's a...
Shure:  只能外卖买了
Shure: We can only buy it through delivery.
Jake: 猫头鹰啊
Jake: An owl.
Lucia: 姜饼
Lucia: Gingerbread.
Jake:姜饼人
Jake: Gingerbread man.
Tasha: 我们买个旺仔牛奶就走吧
Tasha: Let's buy some Wangzai milk and leave.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where's everyone?
Jake:姜饼猫头鹰怎么了
Jake: What's up with the gingerbread owl?
Katrina:  旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 走,go
Tasha: Let's go, go.
Tasha: 然后就没了
Tasha: And then that's it.
Jake: 好在哪里
Jake: Okay, where is it?
Tasha: 在哪里牛奶区吧
Tasha: It's in the milk section, I think.
Katrina: 好像没有逛到旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Seems like we didn't see any Wangzai Milk.
Tasha: 他们家不一定有旺仔牛奶
Tasha: They might not have Wangzai Milk.
Katrina: 人 类是这样的
Katrina: People are like that.
Katrina:  因为人活着累
Katrina: Because life is tiring.
Shure:  洗了算了
Shure: Just wash it and forget it.
Katrina:  哎呀对不起
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Alice:哎呦哦没事
Alice: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No, there's nothing.
Shure: 完了追尾了
Shure: Oops, we had a rear-end collision.
Alice: 因为他们家有自自营的那种牛奶
Alice: Because they have their own brand of milk.
Lucia: 算了吧那就走吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's go.
Katrina:  也没有吗
Katrina: There's none?
Katrina:  没有就不一样了
Katrina: If there's none, it's different.
Alice:对就不一定有旺仔的
Alice: Right, they don't necessarily have Wangzai.
Katrina:  是不是跟他们有品牌竞争啊
Katrina: Is it because they have brand competition?
Katrina: 利益冲突
Katrina: Conflict of interest.
Tasha: 因为他们有那个自营的
Tasha: Because they have their own brand.
Katrina: 自营嘛对
Katrina: Right, their own brand.
Shure:  都是他们的竞品哦
Shure: They're all their competitors.
Lucia: 所以盒马对标当然是
Lucia: So Hema's target is definitely them.
Katrina: 全员竞品啊
Katrina: Everyone is a competitor.
Katrina: 汇源果汁也没有
Katrina: No Huiyuan juice either.
Tasha: 你是因为镜头在录
Tasha: Is it because of the camera recording?
Katrina: 桃汁也没有
Katrina: No peach juice either.
Jake:没有那你为什么要打我
Jake: If there's none, why did you hit me?
Shure: 那种山姆吧我感觉
Shure: Maybe it's like Sam's Club, I think.
Katrina: 自营为什么不出桃汁呢
Katrina: Why doesn't their own brand have peach juice?
Jake:为了把你丢这个钻石丢在我的身上啊
Jake: To throw that diamond on me, of course.
Lucia: 如果自营有同品类的话会形成竞争而且这样他们可以降低成本
Lucia: If their own brand has similar products, it forms competition and they can reduce costs.
Jake:就是你打我然后丢了钻石
Jake: So you hit me and lost the diamond.
Lucia: 不管是制造成本还是
Lucia: Whether it's manufacturing costs or...
Katrina:  嗯还有听你讲经济学原理
Katrina: Hmm, listening to you talk about economics.
Tasha: 这里有汉堡
Tasha: There's a burger here.
Shure:  好像现在那个美团也在搞
Shure: Seems like Meituan is also doing it now.
Shure:  那个小象超市但是他目前都是线上的
Shure: That Xiaoxiang Supermarket, but it's all online for now.
Jake:真的可以做哎
Jake: It can really be done.
Tasha: 可以多要做汉堡
Tasha: We can make more burgers.
Tasha: 芝士芝士芝士皮
Tasha: Cheese, cheese, cheese crust.
Katrina: 啊我刚看到了
Katrina: Ah, I just saw it.
Shure:  而且
Shure: And
Shure:  咱们那个地方还不在那个小象
Shure: Our place isn't in that little elephant
Shure:  超市配送区
Shure: Supermarket delivery area.
Lucia: 如果他能掌控整个供应链的话
Lucia: If he can control the entire supply chain,
Lucia: 就能把成本降到最低
Lucia: He can bring the cost down to the lowest.
Lucia: 但是像京东什么物流这些都是自己做的嘛
Lucia: But like JD and their logistics, they do it all themselves.
Jake:听起来也还行吧
Jake: Sounds okay, right?
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 人呢
Tasha: Where is everyone?
Lucia: 你真的要做吗
Lucia: Are you really gonna do it?
Katrina:  咱自己自助吗
Katrina: Are we doing self-service?
Shure:  而且盒马他们那个配送费你满39
Shure: Also, Hema's delivery fee is waived if you spend over 39.
Jake:可以做
Jake: We can do it.
Shure:  他就免配送
Shure: They waive the delivery fee.
Jake:那就做呗
Jake: Then let's do it.
Tasha: 你想吃吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat?
Shure:  就是其实很 方便
Shure: It's actually very convenient.
Katrina: 我们自己扫
Katrina: We'll scan ourselves.
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat.
Katrina: 还是去那自己扫吧
Katrina: Let's go scan ourselves.
Tasha: 算了KFC可以买
Tasha: Forget it, we can buy KFC.
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake: 好啊好啊
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 在哪里啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake: 结账去了应该
Jake: Probably went to check out.
Jake: 收银区去了
Jake: Went to the checkout area.
Alice: 他人呢
Alice: Where is he?
Alice:开始结账了吗
Alice: Started checking out?
Lucia: 那里有一个取消交易
Lucia: There's a cancel transaction there.
Tasha: 你想要我帮你打个折吗
Tasha: Do you want me to get you a discount?
Jake: 怎么折啊
Jake: How do you get a discount?
Tasha: 怎么折
Tasha: How to get a discount?
Jake: 你有盒马的折吗
Jake: Do you have a Hema discount?
Lucia: 我这个头发怎么老是乱七八糟
Lucia: My hair is always messy.
Jake:还是什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean by "still"?
Tasha: 借的会员
Tasha: Borrowed membership.
Jake: 借的会员
Jake: Borrowed membership.
Tasha: 那肯定要借嘛
Tasha: Of course we have to borrow it.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Shure:  到您了
Shure: It's your turn
Jake: 到已经扫完了
Jake: But it's already scanned
Shure:  没有得先扫会员码
Shure: No, you need to scan the membership code first
Jake: 哦那我也没有啊
Jake: Oh, I don't have one
Alice: 普通会员不就行了吗
Alice: Regular membership is fine, right?
Shure:  不是就必须
Shure: No, it has to be...
Katrina: 你们谁有会员
Katrina: Does anyone have a membership?
Alice:普通会员就可以了
Alice: Regular membership is okay
Tasha: 找88会员
Tasha: Look for the 88 membership
Shure:  我来吧
Shure: I'll do it
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Alright
Katrina:  88VIP有盒马吗
Katrina: Does 88VIP work at Hema?
Tasha: 找88会呃不是88折盒马哦
Tasha: Look for the 88... no, Hema with 88 discount
Jake: 哦所以你有是吧
Jake: Oh, so you have it?
Tasha: 呃我我呃等一下
Tasha: Uh, I... wait a second
Jake: 修硕有还是
Jake: Does Shure have it or...
Lucia: 我甚至没有盒马APP
Lucia: I don't even have the Hema app
Shure:  我有盒马APP
Shure: I have the Hema app
Jake:我也我也没有我也没有
Jake: I don't, I don't have it either
Shure:  但我好像卡里没有那么多钱
Shure: But I don't think I have enough money in my card
Tasha: 对我我还有优惠券
Tasha: Right, I still have coupons
Lucia: 咱们都很少用
Lucia: We rarely use it
Alice: 你点不到啊
Alice: You can't click on it?
Lucia: 盒马是必须要用APP才能结账的
Lucia: You need the app to check out at Hema
Lucia: 我刚回国的时候跟我爸逛了一趟
Lucia: When I first came back to the country, I went shopping with my dad
Lucia: 发现只能用APP结账
Lucia: Found out you can only check out with the app
Lucia: 我就出去了什么也没买
Lucia: So I left without buying anything
Jake:哈哈哈那你要坐两个拖车的话
Jake: Haha, so if you want to take two carts...
Jake: 然后怎么放回去
Jake: How do you put them back?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 就是因为那天拿的东西其实也不太行
Lucia: Because the stuff we got that day wasn't great either
Jake:打的东西还行
Jake: The stuff was okay
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay
Alice:哎为什么用不了呢
Alice: Hey, why can't we use it?
Shure: 杨老板要不给给你弄一个
Shure: Jake, let me get one for you
Shure:  好啊支付宝有吧
Shure: Do you have Alipay?
Jake:好
Jake: Yes
Jake: 支付宝有啊
Jake: I have Alipay
Shure:  那支付宝也行
Shure: Alipay works too.
Shure:  支付宝里有二维码
Shure: There's a QR code in Alipay.
Jake: 支付宝还是有
Jake: Alipay still has it.
Alice: 我打开APP
Alice: I'll open the app.
Alice: 不知道为什么点不了二维码
Alice: Not sure why I can't click the QR code.
Alice: 是不是因为我们开着那个啥的
Alice: Is it because we have that thing on?
Alice: 哦但你一关那个啥不就停那啥了吗
Alice: Oh, but if you turn that thing off, it will stop, right?
Alice:把我家地址录上了没关系吧
Alice: Is it okay if I recorded my home address?
Lucia: 他们会处理好像
Lucia: They will handle it, I think.
Tasha: 有有有有
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:对回头会看一眼
Jake: Yeah, we'll check it later.
Jake: 那个看一眼这谁的手机
Jake: Whose phone is this?
Katrina: 这谁的手机他的吗
Katrina: Whose phone is this, his?
Jake: 这个压力还是挺大的
Jake: The pressure is pretty high.
Jake: 把你们的片都看一遍
Jake: I have to watch all of your videos.
Lucia: 我加油
Lucia: I'll cheer up.
Katrina: 你用试试
Katrina: You try it.
Shure: 减20块钱
Shure: Get 20 yuan off.
Alice:不过没关系
Alice: But it's okay.
Lucia: 因为我觉得我看手机的时候
Lucia: Because when I look at my phone,
Katrina: 这样也可以啊
Katrina: This way works too.
Lucia: 肯定会看到我家地址
Lucia: I will definitely see my home address.
Lucia: 或者之类的类似的东西
Lucia: Or something similar.
Tasha: 我一打开APP就默认我家地址
Tasha: As soon as I open the app, it defaults to my home address.
Tasha: 我的外送地址
Tasha: My delivery address.
Katrina: 不是你有会员吗
Katrina: Don't you have a membership?
Lucia: 我也是
Lucia: Me too.
Lucia: 我今天打开淘宝查材料包的时候也是
Lucia: When I opened Taobao to check the material package today.
Katrina:  也就用你的呗
Katrina: Just use yours.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  用你的然后让他给你报呗
Katrina: Use yours and let him reimburse you.
Lucia: 辛苦了哈哈
Lucia: Thanks, haha.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Alice: 开始
Alice: Start.
Jake: 发生了什么
Jake: What happened?
修硕；来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure:  没事可以开始了
Shure: It's okay, you can start.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我们要不要再拿一个车过来
Lucia: Should we get another car?
Shure:  再拿一个道吧
Shure: Grab another one.
Jake: 插个电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Alice: 我也是吧
Alice: Me too.
Alice: 我能看到
Alice: I can see it.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:咱咱眼睛插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it in.
Jake:别别最后挂掉了
Jake: No, no, it might shut down.
Jake: 你的电还在吗
Jake: Is your battery still good?
Jake:还有挺好挺好
Jake: Still good, still good.
Alice:我的电还在
Alice: My battery is still good.
Jake: 我们这些东西怎么带走啊
Jake: How do we carry all this stuff?
Tasha: 袋子装
Tasha: In bags.
Jake:袋子哦
Jake: Bags, right.
Lucia: 有种给自己脑子接口一样的感觉
Lucia: It feels like I'm plugging into my brain.
Shure: 先扫俩袋子然后边扫边装
Shure: First, scan two bags, then pack as you scan.
Tasha: 就跟自己是个AI机器人给自己充电
Tasha: It's like being an AI robot charging itself.
Katrina: 在哪扫袋子
Katrina: Where do we scan the bags?
Jake:给充电对对对电没了
Jake: Yeah, charge it, charge it, the battery's dead.
Tasha: 你怎么可以
Tasha: How can you...
Alice:放你包里吗先
Alice: Put it in your bag first?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 我可熟练了
Jake: I'm really good at this.
Jake: 没有人比我更熟练
Jake: No one is better than me.
Lucia: 在哪拿呀
Lucia: Where do we get it?
Katrina: 哇这积分极爽了
Katrina: Wow, the points are fantastic.
Lucia: 哇我去看一下
Lucia: Wow, I'll go check it out.
Lucia: 我去看一下
Lucia: I'll go check it out.
Jake:我来帮您来
Jake: Let me help you.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Okay, thank you.
Jake:我觉得自己这确实有点难
Jake: I think this is actually a bit difficult.
Jake:多少拿着点啊
Jake: Take some more, huh?
Jake: 挺好这个袋子
Jake: This bag is pretty good.
Jake:疼吗
Jake: Does it hurt?
Lucia: 我们那边自助结账的话也是在这拿吗
Lucia: For self-checkout, do we get it here too?
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Are we done?
Jake:好了
Jake: Done.
Lucia: 大袋大袋
Lucia: Big bag, big bag.
Jake:好了好了
Jake: Done, done.
Lucia: 呃再来一个吧东西有点多
Lucia: Uh, let's get another one, there's quite a bit of stuff.
Lucia: 行好
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 我们可以把这个袋先扫一下
Lucia: We can scan this bag first.
Lucia: 他说要扫一下然后好吧拿了俩
Lucia: He said to scan it first, and then he took two.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 好哎好了
Tasha: Okay, done.
Jake:好了啊
Jake: Done, right?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 就跟打针一样
Tasha: It's just like getting a shot.
Jake:哈哈哈他妈他妈
Jake: Haha, mom, mom.
Lucia: 然后就可以往里走
Lucia: Then we can go inside.
Lucia: 怎么感觉好像两个袋也不够
Lucia: Why does it feel like two bags aren't enough?
Tasha: 可以先结账
Tasha: We can pay first.
Tasha: 这个已经优惠10块钱了
Tasha: This already has a 10 yuan discount.
Katrina:  先结一部分是吗
Katrina: Pay part of it first, right?
Tasha: 对然后再扫
Tasha: Yes, then scan again.
Tasha: 然后还有两张券
Tasha: And we still have two coupons.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Jake: 他是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 每100每500省10块
Jake: Save 10 yuan for every 100 or 500?
Tasha: 不是我的红包券好不好
Tasha: No, it's my red envelope coupon, okay?
Tasha: 我在牺牲我自己
Tasha: I'm sacrificing myself.
Shure:  哈哈哦哦
Shure: Haha, oh.
Jake:哦哦可以感感谢老板捐10块钱
Jake: Oh, thank you, boss, for donating 10 yuan.
Katrina: 那就先付吧
Katrina: Then let's pay first.
Jake: 好这是10块钱捐赠是吧
Jake: Okay, this is a 10 yuan donation, right?
Jake: 哎这些扫没扫呢
Jake: Hey, have we scanned these?
Shure:  哎怎么扫
Shure: Hey, how do we scan?
Jake:应该怎么扫阿里pay吗
Jake: How should we scan, with Alipay?
Lucia: 都是扫过的呢
Lucia: They're all scanned.
Shure:  都是扫过的
Shure: They're all scanned.
Lucia: 这个车里的车还没扫呢
Lucia: The stuff in this cart hasn't been scanned.
Lucia: 那边应该都扫过了
Lucia: Everything over there should be scanned.
Lucia: 那这呃这俩袋子也不够好像
Lucia: These two bags don't seem to be enough either.
Lucia: 系一下别混一块了
Lucia: Tie them up, don't mix them up.
Katrina:  行吧再再要一个袋子是吧
Katrina: Alright, let's get another bag, right?
Alice:心痛
Alice: Ouch, my heart hurts.
Tasha: 真的能付成功吗可以吧
Tasha: Can we really pay successfully? We can, right?
Tasha: 哦可以的
Tasha: Oh, we can.
Katrina:  我们怎么提回去
Katrina: How do we take these back?
Katrina: 打车就在楼下
Katrina: The taxi is right downstairs.
Jake:100刀100新币
Jake: 100 dollars, 100 SGD.
Shure:  100新币对
Shure: 100 SGD, right.
Jake:一车就100新币
Jake: One ride is 100 SGD.
Shure:  不到100新币
Shure: Less than 100 SGD.
Jake: 我每次一塑料袋100新币
Jake: Every time, one plastic bag is 100 SGD.
Shure:  杨老板就是大气
Shure: Jake is really generous.
Lucia: 没到一车呢
Lucia: It's not even one ride yet.
Lucia: 这边才装了
Lucia: Just loaded this side.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK OK.
Jake: 那可能是400金币
Jake: That might be 400 gold coins.
Jake: 我估计
Jake: I guess.
Tasha: 这个结过账的
Tasha: This one has been settled.
Lucia: 对这这里也都结了
Lucia: Yes, here is also settled.
Lucia: 这里这里好像还没结吧
Lucia: Here, here, seems not settled yet.
Katrina:  放台上没有
Katrina: Not placed on the table.
Katrina:  没有放台上
Alice:这怎么放呢
Alice: How to place this?
Lucia: 先把这的都挪到这
Lucia: Move all of this here first.
Jake:再来一个车
Jake: Another car.
Jake: 我再来一辆车
Jake: I'll get another car.
Jake: 再来一辆车
Jake: Another car.
Jake:不用用了哦OK好嘞
Jake: No need to use it, OK, all right.
Lucia: 就把这个都挪过来然后
Lucia: Just move this over and then...
Lucia: 那边装完的放到这个车里
Lucia: Put the loaded ones into this car.
Tasha: 她说什么
Tasha: What did she say?
Katrina: 就是没结是吗
Katrina: It's not settled, right?
Jake:结账要先下载好盒马APP才能结账
Jake: To settle the bill, you need to download the Hema app first.
Katrina: 那就交换一下
Katrina: Then just exchange it.
Katrina: 在那边装袋吧
Katrina: Pack it over there.
Tasha: 新加坡没有盒马是吗
Tasha: There's no Hema in Singapore, right?
Jake: 应该没有
Jake: Probably not.
Lucia: 那新加坡那边是什么样的超市
Lucia: So what kind of supermarket is there in Singapore?
Lucia: 就这种天生纤维的这种
Lucia: Like this natural fiber kind?
Tasha: 我听说新加坡那边都说中文
Tasha: I heard people in Singapore speak Chinese.
Katrina: 呀感觉还需要袋子
Katrina: Feels like we need more bags.
Lucia: 全食吗
Lucia: Whole Foods?
Jake:不是就是他们有一家fire price
Jake: No, they have one called Fair Price.
Jake: 应该是政府给了很多补贴的
Jake: It should be heavily subsidized by the government.
Jake: 哦叫fire price
Jake: Oh, it's called Fair Price.
Lucia: 他们本地的一个我看
Lucia: It's one of their local ones, I think.
Jake: 很便宜对对对
Jake: Very cheap, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个线老是让我弄得很奇怪
Lucia: This cable always makes me feel weird.
Jake:哎我帮你
Jake: Hey, let me help you.
Jake:要不就是这个放你后面
Jake: Or maybe put this behind you.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure:  再来一个袋
Shure: Another bag, please.
Lucia: 有点卷插头
Lucia: The plug is a bit tangled.
Tasha: 结过账了
Tasha: Paid already.
Katrina:  对方台上都是结过账
Katrina: Yes, everything on the table is paid.
Lucia: 给他弄直一点
Lucia: Straighten it out for him.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 要不然好像我动着动着
Lucia: Otherwise, if I keep moving,
Lucia: 他就快要把我缠起来了
Lucia: it feels like it's going to wrap around me.
Katrina: 哈真买了很多饮料
Katrina: Haha, really bought a lot of drinks.
Jake:这个是久经验证的插电姿势
Jake: This is a tried and true way to plug it in.
Jake:对其实在后面绕过来最好后面贴个胶
Jake: Actually, it's best to loop it from the back and tape it there.
Lucia: 你是做过多少次这样类似的实验了
Lucia: How many times have you done similar experiments?
Jake: 对这个1月份到的
Jake: Yeah, this arrived in January.
Jake: 我带着这个到处
Jake: I took this everywhere.
Jake: 就看比赛啊
Jake: Just to watch games.
Jake: 进城都带着这个东西
Jake: I took it to the city to watch games.
Jake: 哦看比赛还可以那
Jake: Oh, it's great for watching games.
Lucia: 那会把比赛整个
Lucia: So you recorded the whole game?
Lucia: 记录建模下来吗
Lucia: Did you model the whole game?
Jake: 这个不会
Jake: No, no.
Jake:这个不会这个就版权的问题
Jake: No, that's a copyright issue.
Jake: 只能扫扫进场的仪式
Jake: I could only scan the entry ceremony.
Tasha: 那
Tasha: So,
Tasha: 那看电影的时候能把电影记下来吗
Tasha: Can you record a movie when you're watching it?
Alice:这个放别的地
Alice: Put this somewhere else.
Lucia: 那也不行吧
Lucia: That wouldn't work either.
Lucia: 也牵涉版权哦
Lucia: That involves copyrights too.
Lucia: 这不就是枪版
Lucia: Isn't that just pirating?
Jake: 哈哈哈这就是枪版
Jake: Hahaha, that's pirating.
Lucia: 3D枪版
Lucia: 3D pirating.
Jake:这就是枪版
Jake: That's pirating.
Lucia: 坐在电影院的体验
Lucia: The experience of sitting in a cinema.
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:我带一个这个进去给你打出来
Jake: I'll take this in and get it for you.
Alice:放点轻的吧
Alice: Make it lighter.
Jake:哈哈我就这个装备进电影院
Jake: Haha, I'm going into the cinema with this gear.
Alice:我觉得这个有点够呛了
Alice: I think that's a bit much.
Katrina: 放点小饮料吧
Katrina: Put in some small drinks.
Lucia: 感觉很酷炫的样子
Lucia: It looks so cool.
Alice:这拖着底抱
Alice: It's dragging on the ground.
Katrina:  这什么呀
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  再来一个
Shure: Another one.
Jake: 感觉两条腿都要断
Jake: Feels like my legs are gonna break.
Shure:  再去拿两个袋
Shure: Go get two more bags.
小Lucia: 再来两个袋
Little Lucia: Get two more bags.
Jake: 耍赖吗
Jake: Are you cheating?
Jake: 这边有冰块
Jake: There's ice over here.
Jake: 保鲜冰块
Jake: Preserved ice.
Jake: 保鲜冰块能吃吗
Jake: Can we eat the preserved ice?
Alice: 呃不能吃
Alice: Uh, no.
Jake: 好吧好吧好吧
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 但是你可以带
Tasha: But you can bring it.
Tasha: 呃也不用吧
Tasha: Uh, never mind.
Jake: 我们用不着吧
Jake: We don't need it, right?
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Tasha: 我问问
Tasha: I'll ask.
Tasha: 这个冰块可以吃吗
Tasha: Can we eat this ice?
Tasha: 姐啊
Tasha: Sis?
Tasha: 这个不能吃
Tasha: We can't eat this.
Katrina:  要多少钱拿
Katrina: How much to take it?
Tasha: 我就是问一问
Tasha: I'm just asking.
Jake: 编辑一下
Jake: Edit it.
Lucia: 矫正视力
Lucia: Correcting vision.
Katrina: 你那个券是多少
Katrina: How much is your voucher?
Katrina: 满多少
Katrina: For how much?
Jake: 我们视力都有问题
Jake: We all have vision problems.
Alice:；500  500
Alice: 500, 500.
Jake: 就是我们6个人一样的问题
Jake: All six of us have the same problem.
Alice:这个结过了吗
Alice: Is this settled?
Jake: 病友
Jake: Patients.
Katrina:  都结过了
Katrina: It's all settled.
Jake: 呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Alice: 放点放点占位置的
Alice: Put some, put some to take up space.
Jake: 对呃这是全景
Jake: Yeah, this is the panoramic view.
Jake: 博主博主
Jake: Blogger, blogger.
Tasha: 探店的博主
Tasha: A blogger visiting the store.
Jake: 对对6人博主
Jake: Yeah, yeah, a blogger with 6 people.
Jake: 博主探店
Jake: The blogger is visiting.
Katrina:  博主能送两个菜吗
Katrina: Can the blogger get two dishes?
Jake: 对网上见就是好吧
Jake: Yeah, meeting online is good.
Jake: 哈哈哈自己开个超市是吧
Jake: Haha, open a supermarket yourself, right?
Jake: 自己开个盒马
Jake: Open your own Hema.
Lucia: 这个也做美食
Lucia: This one also does food.
Lucia: 哈哈对我们有美食专家
Lucia: Haha, yeah, we have a food expert.
Tasha: 哎等一下别再扫了
Tasha: Hey, wait a minute, don't scan anymore.
Tasha: 还还可以用下一个券呢
Tasha: You can still use another coupon.
Alice: 还没到500呢
Alice: It hasn't reached 500 yet.
Tasha: 不用到500
Tasha: No need to reach 500.
Alice:那你多少
Alice: Then how much?
Tasha: 满20 哈哈哈
Tasha: Over 20, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈满20满20
Jake: Hahaha, over 20, over 20.
Alice:来最后一个
Alice: Come on, the last one.
Alice:随便拿几个券
Alice: Just take a few coupons.
Tasha: 我不确定满多少
Tasha: I'm not sure how much.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me check.
Alice: 你先你先把那个满500的那个10块钱用了
Alice: You use the 500 one first for 10 yuan.
Jake: 凑到了500
Jake: Reached 500.
Tasha: 满49和满29哎
Tasha: Over 49 and over 29, hey.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 满29的水果券
Tasha: Over 29 fruit coupon.
Jake: 先用49的
Jake: Use the 49 one first.
Tasha: 这个是用的什么券
Tasha: Which coupon is this?
Shure:  哎差不多差不多
Shure: Yeah, almost, almost.
Shure:  无所谓无所谓
Shure: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Tasha: 这是水果卷
Tasha: This is the fruit coupon.
Katrina: 要吗
Katrina: Do you want it?
Jake: 他一天能扫这么多
Jake: He can scan so much in a day.
Tasha: 还有一个海鲜券
Tasha: There's also a seafood coupon.
Shure:  给杨老板省了不到一新币
Shure: Saved Jake less than one Singapore dollar.
Alice:有海鲜吗
Alice: Is there seafood?
Katrina: 海鲜是不是扫完了
Katrina: Is the seafood scanned?
Alice:我们买海鲜了吗
Alice: Did we buy seafood?
Katrina:  没有买海鲜
Katrina: Didn't buy any seafood.
Jake: 一新币很重要的
Jake: One Singapore dollar is very important.
Tasha: 那好吧那就扫不完了
Tasha: Alright then, we can't scan everything.
Jake: 一新币可以
Jake: One Singapore dollar can...
Lucia: 虾虾虾滑算海鲜吗
Lucia: Does shrimp ball count as seafood?
Shure:  可口可乐能买吗
Shure: Can we buy Coca-Cola?
Jake: 买不了哈哈哈
Jake: Can't buy it, haha.
Tasha: 虾滑算海鲜吗
Tasha: Does shrimp ball count as seafood?
Tasha: 完了那部分被我
Tasha: Oh no, that part got...
Tasha: 们扫掉了
Tasha: Scanned by us.
Shure:  没事的没事的
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 算了吧
Katrina: Forget it.
Shure:  就这样吧
Shure: Let's leave it like this.
Katrina: 买了1,000块钱
Katrina: Spent 1,000 dollars.
Jake: 1新币能干嘛呢
Jake: What can you do with one Singapore dollar?
Katrina:  省十块也没有
Katrina: Not even saving ten dollars.
Tasha: 好吧那扫吧
Tasha: Alright, let's scan.
Katrina:  那就只有这一个券是吗
Katrina: Is this the only coupon?
Tasha: 这个是不是扫过了
Tasha: Has this been scanned already?
Alice:我这个扫了吗
Alice: Did I scan this?
Tasha: 坐公交或许
Tasha: Maybe for taking the bus...
Jake: 坐不了哈哈
Jake: Can't take the bus, haha.
Katrina:  这两个扫了
Katrina: These two have been scanned.
Katrina: 这个我忘了
Katrina: I forgot about this one.
Katrina:  这个午餐肉扫了吗
Katrina: Has this lunch meat been scanned?
Alice:这还没扫
Alice: This one hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 呃得一块七
Jake: Uh, it's one seventy.
Shure:  哎呀呀呀
Shure: Oh no, oh no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  你又加了一个
Shure: You added one more.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  那什么你刚才不小心加了一个
Shure: You accidentally added one just now.
Katrina:  那个但是他是这个吗
Katrina: But is it this one?
Tasha: 这个吗
Tasha: Is it this one?
Katrina:  他们那边公交路上
Katrina: Their bus route...
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: It's not.
Jake: 不知道耶
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  这没扫吧
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, right?
Jake: 可能
Jake: Maybe.
Jake: 国内也是两块钱
Jake: It's also two bucks back home.
Katrina: 这没扫没扫
Katrina: This hasn't been scanned, hasn't been scanned.
Jake: 没错没错
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Jake: 这边也是两
Jake: It's two here too.
Jake: 那边也两块钱
Jake: And two bucks over there too.
Jake: 国内刷支付宝只要这
Jake: Scanning with Alipay back home only costs this.
Alice: 感觉不能再装了
Alice: I don't think we can pack anymore.
Alice:这个装巨多饮料
Alice: This bag is already full of drinks.
Tasha: 这个扫过了是吧
Tasha: This one's scanned, right?
Alice: 扫过了这都是扫过的
Alice: It's scanned, these are all scanned.
Katrina:  桌上都是扫过的
Katrina: Everything on the table is scanned.
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  不好意思
Shure: My bad.
Tasha: 这个真的还能装沉的吗
Tasha: Can this really hold more weight?
Tasha: 小瓶子放进去OK
Tasha: Small bottles are fine to put in.
Tasha: 主要是这个重量
Tasha: It's mainly about the weight.
Tasha: 这里面好像饮料比较多
Tasha: There seems to be a lot of drinks in here.
Tasha: 别别别压他了别压他了
Tasha: Don't stack on him, don't stack on him.
Tasha: 好了万一托着底抱托着底抱
Tasha: Alright, just support the bottom, support the bottom.
Tasha: 能扎上吗
Tasha: Can you tie it?
Jake: 我来扎我来扎
Jake: I'll tie it, I'll tie it.
Lucia: 这个这把这个拿起来
Lucia: Take this one up.
Lucia: 然后把这个放在这扎
Lucia: Then put this here and tie it.
Lucia: 可能好扎一些
Lucia: It might be easier to tie.
Jake: 哎呦进不去
Jake: Oh no, it won't go in.
Shure:  妈呀这个一会
Shure: Oh man, this one...
Lucia: 这个好重
Lucia: This is so heavy.
Katrina: 这水自带的吧
Katrina: Is this water from home?
Jake: 分两袋吧
Jake: Let's split it into two bags.
Tasha: 分两车吧
Tasha: Let's split it into two carts.
Jake: 再来辆车
Jake: Get another cart.
Jake: 我来开车
Jake: I'll drive it.
小微；你去吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Jake: 我去开车
Jake: I'll go get the car.
Lucia: 这个这个袋子有点太重了
Lucia: This bag is a bit too heavy.
Lucia: 一个可能撑不住
Lucia: One might not hold it.
Tasha: 我感觉应该分散一点吧
Tasha: I think we should spread it out a bit.
Shure: 这撑不住的
Shure: This can't hold it.
Shure:  这个太太那什么了
Shure: It's too much.
Lucia: 就是得抱着
Lucia: We have to hold it carefully.
Lucia: 拿两瓶饮料重要出来
Lucia: Take out two bottles of drinks.
Lucia: 然后放到这里面可以吗
Lucia: And put them in here, okay?
Lucia: 这个够重这重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy enough?
Alice:这个倒是不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Shure:  不要把一个鸡蛋装在同一个篮子里哦
Shure: Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 拿一些这种轻的东西放在这个袋子里
Tasha: Put some of these lighter things in this bag.
Katrina: 这蓝莓好大呀
Katrina: These blueberries are huge.
Jake: 车到了
Jake: The car's here.
Lucia: 要要不要再拿瓶饮料出来
Lucia: Should we take another bottle of drink out?
Lucia: 那个这个
Lucia: This one, this one.
Lucia: 这个现在重吗
Lucia: Is this heavy now?
Alice: 这个不重
Alice: This isn't heavy.
Lucia: 我们要是还有别的那还得有别的袋子
Lucia: If we have more stuff, we'll need another bag.
Lucia: 那这个就放这吧
Lucia: Then just put this here.
Katrina:  他没有布袋子吗
Katrina: Don't they have cloth bags?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Tasha: 能不能租个推车回去
Tasha: Can we rent a cart to take it back?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 谢谢会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Thanks, won't it be a bit heavy?
Tasha: 你不会在思考这个可行性吧
Tasha: Are you considering the feasibility of this?
Tasha: 不可以
Tasha: No.
Jake: 真的吗问问
Jake: Really? Ask about it.
Katrina: OK 啦这水不是的吧
Katrina: OK, this water isn't it?
Lucia: 这都是一些怕压的东西
Lucia: These are all fragile items.
Shure:  咱把他们放到最上面吧
Shure: Let's put them on top.
Lucia: 这个这个还行估计这个先放这里边
Lucia: This one is fine, let's put this here first.
Lucia: 像草莓鸡蛋这种这种
Lucia: Things like strawberries and eggs.
Alice: 这个可以放这个
Alice: This can go here.
Lucia: 哎这俩是一块的
Lucia: Hey, these two go together.
Alice:对这俩是一块
Alice: Yeah, they go together.
Alice:这是送的
Alice: These are complimentary.
Tasha: 有车吗
Tasha: Is there a car?
Tasha: 你摄像头呢
Tasha: Where's your camera?
Shure:  有吧等一会等一会
Shure: Should be, wait a bit, wait a bit.
Jake: 这个没电了
Jake: This is out of battery.
Jake: 这些先放车里吧
Jake: Let's put these in the car first.
Jake: 头掉了
Jake: The head fell off.
Katrina:  饮料要先放下边吧
Katrina: Shouldn't the drinks go at the bottom?
Katrina:  还是一会再放吧
Katrina: Or should we put them later?
Katrina:  太大了把饮料先垫下边
Katrina: It's too big, put the drink underneath first.
Lucia: 我们还有袋子吗
Lucia: Do we still have any bags?
Shure: 你放着吧
Shure: Just put it there.
Lucia: 没有的话应该也能装下
Lucia: If not, we should still be able to fit it.
Shure: 对这个能装
Shure: Yeah, this one can fit.
Lucia: 对要不把这个
Lucia: Yeah, or put this one.
Lucia: 我这底下已经放了一个饮料了
Lucia: I've already put a drink at the bottom.
Lucia: 还能压吗
Lucia: Can it still be pressed down?
Shure:  没事你压
Shure: It's okay, press it down.
Katrina: 还有维c
Katrina: There's still Vitamin C.
Lucia: 这个袋子是不是太重了
Lucia: Is this bag too heavy?
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: If so...
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  付钱喽
Katrina: Time to pay.
Shure:  付钱喽
Shure: Time to pay.
Jake: 送的呀
Jake: It's a gift.
Alice:付钱喽
Alice: Time to pay.
Shure: 付喽楼
Shure: Time to pay.
Tasha: 9块钱要买厨房湿巾吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy kitchen wipes for 9 yuan?
Shure:  来拿着
Shure: Here, take it.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Tasha: 因为不是吃火锅吗
Tasha: Because aren't we having hotpot?
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  拿着
Shure: Take it.
Tasha: 9块钱好像
Tasha: It's about 9 yuan.
Tasha: 啊9.9
Tasha: Oh, 9.9 yuan.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 我真的还有这么多钱吗
Tasha: Do I really have that much money left?
Shure:  我相信你是个大富婆
Shure: I believe you're a rich lady.
Tasha: 你信错了
Tasha: You believe wrong.
Lucia: 这个这个能放到这吗
Lucia: Can this fit here?
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Katrina: 拿着
Katrina: Take it.
Shure:  鸡蛋甭着吧
Shure: Don't worry about the eggs.
Lucia: 先这样吧
Lucia: Let's do it this way for now.
Lucia: 然后我们一会可以再看怎么样
Lucia: Then we can check it again later.
Lucia: 整理一下好
Lucia: Let's organize it well.
Shure:  我天啊
Shure: Oh my God.
Lucia: 这还有有包葱
Lucia: There's also a bag of green onions.
Tasha:这结了吗
Tasha: Is this settled?
Alice: 这不是葱吗
Alice: Isn't this a green onion?
Lucia: 这不是大蒜苗吗
Lucia: Isn't this garlic chives?
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over.
Alice:一样的一样的
Alice: Same thing, same thing.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Shure:  谁不是谁把葱
Shure: Who isn't, who brought the green onions?
Shure:  哎呀哈哈
Shure: Oh, haha.
Lucia: 再买一个吧
Lucia: Let's buy another one.
Tasha: 可以可以买
Tasha: Okay, we can buy it.
Lucia: 啊不是我觉得他是葱
Lucia: Ah no, I think it's a green onion.
Lucia: 他是葱同志们要不要看一眼
Lucia: It's a green onion, guys, do you want to take a look?
Tasha: 蒜苗就是蒜苗
Tasha: Garlic chives are garlic chives.
Shure:  蒜苗就是蒜苗
Shure: Garlic chives are garlic chives.
Tasha: 这这是蒜苗呀
Tasha: This is garlic chives.
Lucia: 这是蒜苗吗
Lucia: Is this garlic chives?
Alice:是是蒜苗
Alice: Yes, it's garlic chives.
Tasha: 是蒜这是一个叠被子
Tasha: It's garlic, this is a folded quilt.
Shure:  完全不是一个味这两个东西
Shure: They taste completely different, these two things.
Tasha: 才买个葱
Tasha: Just buy a green onion.
Katrina: 啊好的
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Alice: 无所谓把它当葱用吧
Alice: Doesn't matter, just use it as green onion.
Alice:也可以
Alice: It's fine.
Shure:  不行他俩完全不是一个味啊
Shure: No, they taste completely different.
Tasha: 不是一个味啊
Tasha: They taste different.
Shure:  蒜苗是蒜的味
Shure: Garlic chives taste like garlic.
Lucia: 我刚才拿起来突然一看
Lucia: I just picked it up and suddenly realized.
Lucia: 这是到底是什么东西
Lucia: What exactly is this thing?
Shure:  那张那张账单在谁那呢
Shure: Who has that bill?
Jake: 可以啊
Jake: It's fine.
Katrina:  就两个呀
Katrina: Just two, right?
Shure:  还有一张账单啊
Shure: There's another bill.
Katrina:  第一个没打是不是
Katrina: Didn't the first one get printed?
Shure:  第一个打了
Shure: The first one got printed.
Tasha: 第一个打了
Tasha: The first one got printed.
Tasha: 谁拿着呢
Tasha: Who's holding it?
Jake: 我我没拿呀
Jake: I didn't take it.
Shure:  忘忘塞到哪了
Shure: Forgot where it was stuffed.
Jake: 我可能没拿吧
Jake: Maybe I didn't take it.
Tasha: 我没拿呀
Tasha: I didn't take it.
Jake: 我应该没拿
Jake: I don't think I took it.
Tasha: 我应该没拿呀
Tasha: I don't think I took it either.
Jake: 那可能就是拿了吧
Jake: Then maybe you did take it?
Alice: 这不两条吗
Alice: Aren't there two pieces?
Tasha: 葱要不要再买一个
Tasha: Should we buy another scallion?
Jake: 两条吗我去
Jake: There are two pieces? I'm going.
Lucia: 哎那怎么又变成两条了
Lucia: Why did it turn into two pieces again?
Lucia: 还有一条
Lucia: There's still one more piece.
Tasha:葱我去拿吧
Tasha: I'll go get the scallion.
Shure: 本来就两条
Shure: There were always two pieces.
Jake: 应该连起来
Jake: They should be connected.
Lucia: 本来就两条
Lucia: There were always two pieces.
Alice:哎哎哎去那边葱
Alice: Hey, hey, hey, go over there for the scallion.
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my, I'm going.
Lucia: 小心这也是咱们的
Lucia: Be careful, this is also ours.
Lucia: 结过账的东西要看好
Lucia: Make sure to keep an eye on the things we've paid for.
Lucia: 对放进来吧
Lucia: Yes, put it inside.
Jake: 去贴门禁
Jake: Go stick the door sticker.
Tasha: 这也太大了
Tasha: This is too big.
Shure:  护蛋使者
Shure: Egg protector.
Alice:啊好烫啊
Alice: Ah, it's so hot.
Katrina: 绝对不能让任何一个蛋受到伤害
Katrina: Definitely can't let any egg get hurt.
Katrina: 封条
Katrina: Sealing tape.
Jake: 那不多
Jake: That's not too much.
Shure:   绶带
Shure: Ribbon.
Jake: 呃买二得三
Jake: Uh, buy two, get three.
Katrina: 你在英国呆有没有人就是抢
Katrina: Have you ever been robbed while staying in the UK?
Katrina: 你有遭遇过抢劫吗
Katrina: Have you ever encountered a robbery?
Lucia: 嗯我倒是没碰到过
Lucia: Hmm, I haven't encountered it.
Lucia: 不过这种事确实挺多的
Lucia: But such things do happen quite often.
Katrina: 会抢吗
Katrina: Will they rob?
Jake: 总共就两条吧
Jake: There are only two pieces in total, right?
Lucia: 哦好像有这种事吧但我没有
Lucia: Oh, it seems like such things happen, but I haven't.
Lucia: 但我没有目睹过
Lucia: But I haven't witnessed it.
Lucia: 据说有我们可以讨论这个吗
Lucia: They say there are, can we discuss this?
Lucia: 涉嫌什么谈论
Lucia: What are we talking about?
Shure: 这个还挺好喝的
Shure: This drink is quite good.
Lucia: 谈论那个
Lucia: 哈哈哈说一些不好的话
Lucia: Hahaha, saying some not-so-good things.
Jake: 没关系就这个翻译给他乱翻译一个
Jake: It's okay, just give him a random translation.
Jake: American is the best
Jake: American is the best.
Alice:结吧结吧
Alice: Okay, let's do it.
Lucia: 会翻译成这样吗
Lucia: Will it be translated like this?
Alice: 这怎么拿回去啊
Alice: How do we take this back?
Katrina:  一人一个
Katrina: One for each person.
Jake: 翻译翻过去就是美国的东西很便宜
Jake: Translate it as "American products are very cheap."
Jake: 大家喜欢买便宜的东西
Jake: Everyone likes to buy cheap stuff.
Lucia: 大家喜欢花最低的价格买东西
Lucia: Everyone likes to buy things at the lowest price.
Katrina:  你的仓库star还没有老乡鸡多
Katrina: Your warehouse isn't even as big as LaoXiangJi.
Jake: 经济很好
Jake: The economy is great.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake: 让眼镜记一下
Jake: Let Glasses take note.
Shure:  给大家报个菜名吧
Shure: Let's name some dishes.
Shure:  眼镜嗯
Shure: Glasses, hmm.
Shure:  窥你的屏看看你的
Shure: Peeking at your screen, let's see.
Shure:  看小红书都有什么
Shure: What's on Little Red Book?
Shure: 咦
Shure: Eh?
Lucia: 这很有品啊
Lucia: This is quite stylish.
Katrina:  这说明我
Katrina: This means I...
Shure:  原来你也喜欢这一口嗯
Shure: So you like this too, huh?
Tasha: 我帮你贴上吗
Tasha: Do you want me to stick this for you?
Jake: 好啊哈哈哈
Jake: Sure, hahaha.
Jake: 你就欠这一刀
Jake: You just need this cut.
Jake: 手带现在这个长度很好
Jake: The strap length is perfect now.
Jake: 就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Alice:走吧
Alice: Let's go.
Shure:  go
Shure: Go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 那芋头还有蛋挞皮
Tasha: So there's taro and tart crusts.
Tasha: 还有刚刚说的薄荷
Tasha: And also the mint we just mentioned.
Jake: 这车能推到哪啊
Jake: Where can we push this cart?
Tasha: 还有你们那个好像还有两个材料
Tasha: And there seem to be two more ingredients.
Shure: 门口
Shure: To the entrance.
Jake: 门口
Jake: The entrance.
Jake: 哪个门口外边
Jake: Which entrance, outside?
Tasha: 就从网上买的
Tasha: Just bought it online.
Alice:什么美文纸
Alice: What beautiful paper?
Shure: here yes
Shure: Here, yes.
Shure:  你好这车最远能推到哪啊
Shure: Hi, how far can this cart go?
Shure:  就到这就到头了
Shure: This is the farthest it can go.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Oh
Shure:  杨老板先把车打上吧
Shure: Jake, start the car first.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们就直接打车了
Jake: We'll just drive directly.
Jake: 不再买点咖啡什么的
Jake: No need to buy coffee or anything.
Jake: 现在有点晚了
Jake: It's a bit late now.
Tasha: 不用喝了
Tasha: No need to drink.
Katrina:  我们直接去吃饭是吗
Katrina: Are we just going to eat directly?
Tasha: 对吃什么呢
Tasha: Yeah, what should we eat?
Shure:  你们确拎着这么多东西
Shure: You guys are carrying so much stuff.
Alice: 这地能有放的吗
Alice: Is there space to put it down here?
Jake: 确实啊
Jake: True.
Shure: 你们肯定得回趟家先那什么
Shure: You definitely need to go home first.
Lucia: 拿这么多东西去吃饭有点
Lucia: It's a bit much to take all this stuff to dinner.
Tasha: 要不就点外卖吧
Tasha: How about we order takeout?
Jake: 行回去点外卖吧
Jake: Okay, let's go home and order takeout.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 都可以一起出去也可以
Lucia: We can all go out together too.
Jake: 在这是就是有冻的东西对吧
Jake: There are frozen items here, right?
Shure:  是吧而且还有要要冻的东西
Shure: Right, and there are things that need to be kept cold.
Jake: 是吧是有冷冻的
Jake: Right, some are frozen.
Jake: 冷冻的东西
Jake: Frozen items.
Shure:  然后大家看一眼那个哪些是冷冻
Shure: Everyone, take a look at what's frozen and what's refrigerated.
Shure:  哪些是冷藏
Shure: What's refrigerated.
Katrina:  放一会吧
Katrina: Let's just leave it for a bit.
Shure:  比如说那毛肚什么的
Shure: Like the tripe.
Shure:  他就是说让0-4度
Shure: It needs to be kept at 0-4 degrees.
Tasha: 你要放下来吗
Tasha: Do you want to put it down?
Jake: 啊再来一辆车你要不
Jake: Ah, do you want another cart?
Shure:  他只能到这儿了
Shure: It can only go this far.
Shure:  爸爸只能送你到这儿了
Shure: Dad can only take you this far.
Shure:  未来的路要靠你自己了
Shure: The rest of the journey is up to you.
Shure:  听到了吗
Shure: Did you hear that?
Shure:  那是你的朗姆的声音
Shure: That's the sound of your destiny calling.
Shure:  他现在向你发出回应
Shure: It's responding to you now.
Katrina:  这样我们的冰箱就满了
Katrina: Now our fridge is full.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 冰箱能不能放下呀
Lucia: Can the fridge hold everything?
Shure:  希望我明天回的时候你不要把它喝了好吗
Shure: Hope you don't drink it all when I come back tomorrow, okay?
Katrina:  哈哈哈全喝光
Katrina: Hahaha, I'll drink it all.
Jake: 回头
Jake: Later
Katrina: 草莓也全吃了
Katrina: I'll eat all the strawberries too.
Jake: 就是这个数据比较重要
Jake: This data is quite important.
Jake: 就是回头你们收拾的时候
Jake: When you clean up later,
Jake: 会和超市
Jake: it will be linked with the supermarket.
Jake: 你们的一些行为建立一些联系
Jake: Your actions will establish some connections.
Jake: 就是比方说你把这东西放到冰箱
Jake: For example, if you put something in the fridge,
Jake: 然后他只能找回到你在哪找到的那个
Jake: it can only trace back to where you found it.
Lucia: 哦那就跟亚马逊那个无人采购超市
Lucia: Oh, just like Amazon's cashierless supermarkets.
Lucia: 一样的那种感觉
Lucia: It feels the same.
Jake: 对对对溯源
Jake: Yeah, yeah, traceability.
Katrina: 溯源啦
Katrina: Traceability!
Jake: 对就是溯源这种rechieve
Jake: Exactly, it's this kind of traceability.
Jake: 特厉害你去不
Jake: It's really impressive, right?
Shure:  你们上链的吗
Shure: Are you guys on the blockchain?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Hehe
Katrina:  当心哦
Katrina: Be careful.
Lucia: 阿莫总开了好几个那种
Lucia: Amos has opened several of those
Lucia: 那种超市
Lucia: kinds of supermarkets.
Lucia: 就是你出门不用结账
Lucia: You don't need to check out when you leave.
Lucia: 他知道你买了什么
Lucia: It knows what you bought.
Lucia: 然后自动在你的账户里付款
Lucia: Then it automatically charges your account.
Lucia: 就是他根据你的重量
Lucia: It goes by the weight,
Lucia: 好像就是你放进去然后东西多重
Lucia: like you put it in and it knows the weight.
Lucia: 对他会精确到多少多少毫克
Lucia: Yeah, it can be accurate to milligrams.
Lucia: 然后呢他就会自动把这钱扣走
Lucia: Then it automatically deducts the money.
Lucia: 是超市里
Lucia: In the supermarket,
Lucia: 就跟我们一样
Lucia: just like ours.
Jake:那我要稍微哎
Jake: Then I need to...
Lucia: 就是它有很多摄像头
Lucia: It has a lot of cameras.
Lucia: 就是能看到你拿了什么
Lucia: They can see what you're taking.
Lucia: 他监测你有没有在货架上拿东西
Lucia: They monitor if you take something off the shelf.
Lucia: 包括你进出的时候的各种数据
Lucia: Including all kinds of data when you enter and leave.
Lucia: 反正很神奇的一个东西
Lucia: It's a really amazing thing.
Lucia: 不过就是偶尔有算错的可能性
Lucia: But sometimes it can make errors.
Shure:  那肯定
Shure: For sure.
Shure:  因为每一个我都这么拿
Shure: Because every time I take something like this,
Lucia: 哎那个好像他也能监测的到
Lucia: Oh, it seems like it can detect that too.
Lucia: 呵呵不过有时候是会算错的
Lucia: Hehe, but sometimes the calculation is wrong.
Shure:  我打个雨伞呐
Shure: I'm holding an umbrella.
Shure:  他肯定检测不到了吧
Shure: He definitely won't detect it, right?
Lucia: 去实验一下
Lucia: Let's test it out.
Jake: 对总之比0元购强
Jake: Yeah, anyway, it's better than getting it for free.
Jake: 就是这是他的玻璃
Jake: This is his glass.
Jake:玻璃好歹还在人抢
Jake: At least people still fight over the glass.
Jake: 好歹还算算法错误
Jake: At least it's still a calculation error.
Shure:  就是我就爱打伞
Shure: I just love holding an umbrella.
Shure:  在室内
Shure: Indoors.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 他有可能是商品上面贴条了
Jake: He might have put a tag on the product.
Jake: 贴无线电
Jake: A radio tag.
Jake: 他还有6分钟到
Jake: He'll be here in 6 minutes.
Alice:开始往下走吧
Alice: Let's start heading down.
Jake: 往上走好像是
Jake: Seems like we should go up.
Jake:这是往上走对吧
Jake: This is the way up, right?
Katrina:  往下吧
Katrina: Let's go down.
Alice:我们不是二楼吗
Alice: Aren't we on the second floor?
Alice:我们是这样上来的呀
Alice: We came up this way.
Jake:哦这么回事啊
Jake: Oh, I see.
Alice: 一进门一进门不是有个升的电梯
Alice: There was an elevator right when we entered.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 有道理
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake: 因为这地方太像地下了
Jake: Because this place really feels like a basement.
Alice: 有点阴森有点不热闹
Alice: It's a bit eerie and not very lively.
Shure:  我在搞地下音乐
Shure: I'm doing underground music.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:有点
Alice: A bit.
Tasha: 你你一个人拎两个
Tasha: You, you carry two by yourself?
Katrina: 就主要是那个酒比较多的那个
Katrina: Mainly because there are more bottles of alcohol.
Jake: 你你你这么厉害吗
Jake: Are you that strong?
Alice: 而且饮料多的比较沉
Alice: And the ones with more drinks are heavier.
Alice: 你再一人掂一掂
Alice: You try carrying one more.
Jake: 这才对嘛
Jake: That's more like it.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  您是
Shure: You are...
Katrina: 没事你你
Katrina: It's okay, you, you...
Katrina: 真的可以这样利用老板吗
Katrina: Can we really use the boss like this?
Shure:  天啊
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:这样比较平衡
Jake: This way it's more balanced.
Shure:  这厨房湿巾一定很沉吧
Shure: These kitchen wipes must be really heavy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这这鸡蛋也很沉吧
Tasha: Hahaha, these eggs must be heavy too.
Lucia: 哈哈这鸡蛋很宝贵
Lucia: Haha, these eggs are precious.
Shure:  对没事
Shure: Right, no problem.
Katrina:  我需要专人护送
Katrina: I need a dedicated escort.
Shure:  我只送到你们到门口
Shure: I'll only escort you to the door.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我这线是掉了吗
Jake: Did my line fall off?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 老板
Tasha: Boss.
Tasha: 老板拎着最多的东西
Tasha: The boss is carrying the most stuff.
Lucia: 真的真的
Lucia: Really, really.
Lucia: 要不要帮你安上
Lucia: Do you want me to help you put it on?
Jake:好啊好啊
Jake: Yeah, sure.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Just a moment.
Lucia: 你别走
Lucia: Don't go.
Jake: OK了开始开动
Jake: Okay, let's get started.
Katrina: connected
Katrina: Connected.
Shure:  这是老板吗
Shure: Is this the boss?
Shure:  我们是被一个AI领导的一群人类
Shure: We are led by an AI, a group of humans.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 呃重吗我跟你一起拎
Tasha: Uh, is it heavy? I'll carry it with you.
Alice:不用不用这个就一个兜啊
Alice: No, no, it's just one bag.
Jake: 就我我头上的和我眼前的
Jake: Just the one on my head and the one in front of me.
Shure: 那个鸡蛋保护起来一定很累把不如我们换一换吧
Shure: It must be exhausting to protect those eggs. How about we switch?
Jake: 就是我的接收设备
Jake: It's just my receiving device.
Jake: 我全靠他来支撑我
Jake: I rely on it to support me.
Katrina: 不行你没有这个资格
Katrina: No, you don't have the qualification.
Jake: 哈哈哈一些行为
Jake: Hahaha, some actions.
Lucia: 这个故事开始向恐怖片方向发展了
Lucia: This story is starting to turn into a horror movie.
Shure: 怎么我保护我保护不了蛋蛋是吗
Shure: What, I can't protect the eggs?
Shure:  但
Shure: But...
Katrina:  蛋蛋
Katrina: Eggs.
Shure: 蛋
Shure: Egg.
Tasha: 这颗葱拐到你的脚了
Tasha: This green onion hit your foot.
Shure: done
Shure: Done.
Tasha: 我帮你拿着
Tasha: I'll hold it for you.
Shure:  你要把鼻音夹进去done
Shure: You need to add a nasal sound in there.
Jake:啊会吗谢谢
Jake: Oh, really? Thanks.
Katrina: 所以他们要
Katrina: So they need to...
Jake: 所以很重要
Jake: So it's very important.
Katrina: 所以你们最后买葱了吗
Katrina: So did you guys finally buy the green onions?
Jake: 哈哈哈所以呢
Jake: Haha, so what?
Jake:哈哈哈critical
Jake: Haha, critical.
Shure: 买了
Shure: We got them.
Alice:买了买了
Alice: Yes, we bought them.
Shure:  买了这么大一节葱白
Shure: We bought a huge bunch of white onions.
Alice:不是这还是蒜苗
Alice: No, it's actually garlic sprouts.
Alice:我们的葱在那个篮里面呢
Alice: Our green onions are in that basket.
Tasha: 买了一个葱姜蒜组合
Tasha: We got a combo of green onions, ginger, and garlic.
Shure:  发明这个的人真是天才
Shure: The person who invented this is a genius.
Jake: 我觉得每人带根线是有点酷啊
Jake: I think everyone having a wire is kinda cool.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:你这么一眼看过去
Jake: When you look at it...
Alice:尤其我们这样走在一起
Alice: Especially when we walk together like this.
Shure: 一会我回程的路上要地铁
Shure: I need to take the subway on my way back.
Alice:感觉像一个什么组织
Alice: It feels like some kind of organization.
Tasha: 有点像一个神秘组织
Tasha: It's like a secret organization.
Shure: 这个数据要录下来吗
Shure: Do we need to record this data?
Jake: 可以录
Jake: We can record it.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Tasha: 尤其这个眼镜还发光的感觉
Tasha: Especially with these glasses that light up.
Katrina: 但他地铁要差不多两个小时
Katrina: But it takes about two hours by subway.
Jake:你地铁你地铁
Jake: Your subway, your subway.
Tasha: 大家都带同一款
Tasha: Everyone's wearing the same model.
Jake: 进个进一下出一下得了
Jake: Just go in and out quickly.
Jake: 你就进去吧
Jake: Just go in.
Jake: 进去然后就关掉
Jake: Go in and then turn it off.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake: 然后主要是你看你答辩
Jake: The main thing is to see your defense.
Jake:哈哈哈你答辩
Jake: Haha, your defense.
Shure:  我答辩真的真的好录吗
Shure: Is it really okay to record my defense?
Shure:  方便吗方便哎
Shure: Is it convenient?
Jake:方便
Jake: It's convenient.
Jake: 你问Andy对吧你的老师Andy
Jake: Ask Andy, right? Your teacher Andy.
Shure:  说我在进行一个奇怪的项目
Shure: Tell him I'm doing a strange project.
Jake: 对你问Andy想不想进数据集
Jake: Yes, ask Andy if he wants to be in the dataset.
Jake: 想不想被人研究研究
Jake: Want to be studied by people?
Shure:  安妮好像英国人会对这
Shure: Annie, it seems like British people are
Shure:  隐私方面更敏感一些吧
Shure: more sensitive about privacy, right?
Lucia: 我们往哪走啊
Lucia: Where are we going?
Lucia: 是这边吗
Lucia: Is it this way?
Alice: 都可以出去
Alice: We can go anywhere.
Tasha: 这边是我们刚刚
Tasha: This way is where we just
Tasha: 最近的那个
Tasha: recently came from.
Katrina:  嗯不不不
Katrina: Hmm, no no no.
Jake: 这是探路去了
Jake: This is the pathfinder.
Jake: 这是北京通州案吗
Jake: Is this the Beijing Tongzhou case?
Shure:  呃也不至于
Shure: Uh, not really.
Katrina:  我觉得也是吧
Katrina: I think it is, though.
Shure: 但是
Shure: But...
Katrina:  这个应该也能出去吧
Katrina: This should be fine to go out too.
Shure:  四五十是常事
Shure: Forty or fifty is common.
Lucia: 我们为什么不从那里出呢
Lucia: Why don't we go out from there?
Jake: 帮我接个电话
Jake: Help me answer a call.
Katrina: 你放地上吧
Katrina: Just put it on the ground.
Jake: 算了我来
Jake: Never mind, I'll do it.
Shure:  要不我送你们到这我就先溜了
Shure: How about I drop you off here, and then I'll head out.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure:  走吧再见
Shure: Let's go, goodbye.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Jake: 哎我想挠头我靠
Jake: Ah, I want to scratch my head, damn it.
Jake: 拜拜明天见
Jake: Bye, see you tomorrow.
Shure:  明天见今晚不要想我哦
Shure: See you tomorrow, don't think about me tonight.
Jake: 喂你好
Jake: Hello, hi.
Shure: 希望不要想我哦
Shure: Hopefully, don't think about me.
Katrina: 希望你答辩顺利哦
Katrina: Hope your defense goes well.
Katrina:  对你就到这了
Katrina: Alright, you stay here.
Shure:  对我就到这了
Shure: Yep, I'll stay here.
Shure:  呃所以你不能只拎一包湿巾
Shure: Uh, so you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Jake: 我按照定位找你吧
Jake: I'll find you based on the location.
Shure:  所以你不能只拎一包湿巾了
Shure: So you can't just carry one pack of wet wipes.
Shure:  拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Shure:  我想想咱们那个是什么来着
Shure: Let me think, what was that?
Alice: 嗯是这个门出去
Alice: Yeah, go out this door.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  咋们下课铃是啥来着
Shure: What's our end-of-class bell sound like again?
Shure:  怎么突然想不起来了
Shure: Why did I suddenly forget?
Shure:  热死了这就是听摇滚的人是吗下课铃都听成了门徒
Shure: It's so hot. Is this what happens when you listen to rock music? Even the school bell sounds like a disciple.
Shure:  啊我现在
Shure: Ah, I am now...
Shure: 我现在准备在
Shure: I am now preparing to...
Shure: 我现在在回去的路上
Shure: I am now on my way back.
Shure: 额 我看一眼是哪个方向
Shure: Uh, let me see which direction it is.
Shure:  复兴门那
Shure: Fuxingmen, that way.
Shure:  OK好OK
Shure: OK, fine, OK.
Shure:  我要坐19站1号线
Shure: I need to take Line 1 for 19 stops.
Shure:  我去
Shure: Oh man...
Shure: 热死了
Shure: It's so hot.
Shure: 原来这种热自身
Shure: So this is what it feels like to be this hot.
Shure:  原来这种没脑子的事不指挥我干嘛
Shure: Why don't you command these brainless tasks to me?
Shure:  怎么你也变傻了
Shure: How come you've become stupid too?
Shure:  先明珠不在了
Shure: Xian Mingzhu is gone.
Shure:  今天
Shure: Today...
Shure:  而且坐他车我感觉不如坐地铁
Shure: And riding in his car, I feel it's not as good as taking the subway.
Shure:  他每次过去也要一个多小时
Shure: Every time it takes him more than an hour.
Shure:  我坐这地铁也是一个小时20分钟
Shure: Taking this subway also takes an hour and twenty minutes.